[Musique]
comment aborde-t-on des municipales
lorsque son parti est historiquement
dispensé de disputer un second tour
'avec confiance' certainement met un peu
de pression tout de même en bon
professeur didier laguerre connaît des
chiffres en 2014 sa liste avait
rassemblé dix mille voix de moins que
son prédécesseur serge letchimy un recul
de 30 points alors le scrutin du 15 mars
révélera la popularité gagné par didier
laguerre en six ans la main tendue et
humanisme politique
didier laguerre se veut fidèle à
l'héritage série mais la majorité est
mise à mal par un déficit de 30 6
millions d'euros est attaqué de toutes
parts à cela sa réponse est le plan de
retour à l'équilibré programmé pour 2027
jeu et ils y soient moins bons mais je
m'adore les économies matures la région
je venais aussi les ordres ou des images
ne me dit pas moi c'est pas une
difficulté de faire campagne et d'avoir
des projets compte tenu du déficit parce
que le plan de redressement et le plan
de retour à l'équilibré ainsi que le
plan d'accompagnement de l'état comprend
l'aller les projets prend en compte les
projets de du coeur de ville l'épousé de
rénovation urbaine et donc les
investissements qui sont projetées sont
compris dans le plan de retour à
l'équilibré
la majorité fouilles à l'aise met en
avant l'accord signé à huit jours avec
les syndicats pour accompagner le
redressement budgétaire
en six ans le nombre d'agents est déjà
passé de 3900 à 2900 et l'effort va
continuer
[Applaudissements]